Donald Trump's latest claim about the
entire not paying taxes debacle is that
he's uniquely positioned to fix the
problems with our tax system because he
just understands the tax code so well
that he believes he is smart for not
paying federal taxes as he was accused
by Hillary Clinton in the first
presidential debate here's a a reminder
of Trump making this claim from Donald
Trump's own Twitter account as you see
saying I know our complex tax laws
better than anyone who has ever run for
president and then the only one who can
fix them Trump is going to have to try
again with another explanation because
it turns out that an attorney who
actually personally oversaw Donald
Trump's income tax returns in the
mid-1990s named Jack mitnick said that
the Republican presidential candidate
has always had little interest in the
tax code and really didn't understand it
nor know anything about it here's a
quote from Jack mitnick he gave an
interview up to NBC's Today saying as
far as I know and that only goes through
late 96 he didn't understand the code
nor would he have had the time and the
patience to learn the provisions that's
a lifetime of experience I love that he
didn't understand the tax code and he
didn't seem interested in learning you
could replace the word tax code to the
phrase tax code with almost any topic
and that statement would still
accurately describe Donald Trump Donald
Trump really didn't understand economics
and he had really no interest in
learning Donald from didn't really
understand abortion legislation and had
absolutely no interest in learning uh
mitnick did oversee the Trump tax
returns in 95 that's the year from which
a portion of the tax return was
published by the New York Times and it
showed that a reported loss of nine
hundred and sixteen million dollars and
Mitnick also went on to tell The Today
Show that we don't know whether that
loss was used to not pay federal income
taxes going forward not a surprise right
we don't have the tax returns from years
following 95 course we have no idea
whether
actually use that loss not to pay taxes
uh mitnick also said something that I
found interesting which is Trump has
always been more of a concept guy and
not really detail-oriented that's pretty
evident from watching the campaign right
hey we're gonna build the wall in Mexico
will pay for it right well the Mexican
president said that he wouldn't it be
very difficult to get the money to build
the wall and be incredibly expensive and
it wouldn't really actually stop the
entire undocumented immigration problem
those are details Trump's the concept
guy so he's not going to get uh
concerned with that yeah go ahead Rachel
yeah yeah but his hip rock his hypocrisy
here is twofold because in 2012 in
January he said to Greta Van Susteren
that Romney was really hurt very badly
by not releasing his active and then he
went on to advise him to release them
and then he went on to praise him once
he did release and saying they were
wonderfully beautiful so I really just
think the hypocrisy here is it's a it's
intense the hypocrisy is actually the
story and I'm glad Rachel brought this
up because I want to clarify the story
of trumps taxes is not specifically a
critique of Trump for taking advantage
of the tax law to apparently pay no
taxes at least some years it's a story
about hypocrisy right when as rachel
says when Trump said that Romney should
release the tax returns when Trump
criticized President Obama for paying 20
point something percent on his seven
hundred and ninety thousand dollar
income when Trump slammed the fifty
percent of Americans that he claims pay
no taxes the hypocrisy is the story and
big picture Donald Trump is not
releasing his tax returns in contrast to
what every presidential candidate for
the last forty years have done the story
is that Trump clearly has something to
hide absolutely anybody who has the
means to pay as little in taxes as
legally possible is doing the obvious
and natural thing I have the option in
Massachusetts or at least I used to on
my state return to opt to pay a higher
rate the Massachusetts state income
taxes five point three percent and you
can opt to pay a higher rate if you just
think taxes should be higher I never did
right I'm going to act to some degree
out of self-interest but I'm not going
to be a hypocrite right I'm going to say
the tax laws have to be changed we can't
just expect people to say I'll just pay
more especially since one person
choosing to pay more not really gonna
make a difference when it comes to
federal and state budget so this is like
the Cuba story right the critique isn't
that the Cuban embargo is really
valuable it's that Trump slammed Cuba uh
the Cuban regime but was simultaneously
actually exploring doing business with
them this is a critique of course of the
tax laws and of Donald Trump's hypocrisy
but it is not a critique merely of Trump
doing what he can legally to avoid
paying taxes that's actually more of a
systemic problem